what's going on guys this is rob and I'm
making this quick video to let you guys
know I don't know if any of you guys
have Hulu or not or if any of you guys
have seen the mid-season finale of
agents of shield but me and Benny
haven't seen it yet and I'm actually
talking to Cameron talking to Cameron on
skype but me and Benny and haven't seen
it I think I'll watched it last night
but what me and Benny are going to do is
at about five o'clock 5pm today we're
going to watch the show on hulu but
we're going to livestream ourselves
watching it I don't know if that makes
any sense or not but what we're actually
doing here we're kind of experimenting
if this is something that is like cool
that'll like a lot of people like like
people are really receptive to it we
might actually just start live streaming
ourselves watching it while we're
watching the show so that what you guys
can watch it in real time and that's
where hulu comes into play if any of you
guys have Hulu and haven't seen the show
yet you can watch it along with us I
don't know if you guys would like this
kind of thing or if you guys might just
be like this is stupid or whatever but
it's just some for us to experiment with
and some for us to try out so so let me
know what you guys think I'll catch you
guys later peace